de magnifiques voiliers sortir et tours
al gore
à battre et cela est derrière mais il se
peut pas courir à osaka est visé c'est
un gros mal tout seul au front
à visière octopus michel dans le voyez
bien ce magnifique sortait de dire à mon
avis pas cette jupe à tongres et r il
faudrait tout de suite atteint le mal
qu'il fait face n'a rien pas content de
faire passer les bosses à ces matches
pour embauche d'un coup quand on quitte
comme ça la ne m'intéresse de voir
vraiment ce qu'il ya comme un excès de
lumière là ça passe pas en vidéo oui ça
passe écrit sony devant les éléphants
tallet ans plus tard prend dès qu'on
commence le shoot si tu veux tu mettant
mise au point ou pas c'était vachement
pour posséder les armes devant et tous
eu beau toit mille petits noms de tout
cela on est en face d'un risque la lie à
puce et où platon